All right, we're good. Hello everybody. It is the middle of August 2018. We've been doing these
Zoom calls for about a year right now, which is hopefully made of blessing to a lot of people,
but I know it does also get overwhelming because if you have just, if you're new to our clinic,
you have 52 videos to catch up on. And that is only about 50 hours. So it's only a week,
so at a week you'll be caught up on everything. Of course, you're going to pause everything
else in your life. But hey, it's worth it to listen to us all that time. I quite honestly,
I have never once listened to one of my videos. I can't stomach it. So I don't know how you guys do it,
but that just tells you the dedication that our patients have in getting better. It's just amazing.
So hats off to all of you. Okay, so we're going to start with a little message. It'll try to keep
it brief. And we have a few questions. Just a few that came in at a number of people asking their
questions on Facebook this week, which is great because then everybody gets the blessing of hearing
those answers as well. And then we'll open it up to questions. So today's little teeny lesson is going
to be on what we all do is human beings that we did it. I believe ever since the Garden of Eden,
we've learned to judge what's good and bad. And I really believe that's the lesson of eating from
the tree of the knowledge of good and evil is that prior to that, we could say that to Adam and Eve
who walked perfectly in relationship with their Heavenly Father, everything was good. The better
what happened in their life, they saw it as good because they had that perfect relationship that
one-on-one relationship with their Heavenly Father. And after eating from the tree of the knowledge,
a good evil one could say that their eyes were opened to be able to judge for themselves what is
good and what is evil. And we do this all the time. How many times do we put labels on things as oh,
that's great. Or that's bad. We do that from the food that we eat to, the events that happen in
our life. All of us are trying to get rid of a disease that we say is bad. We don't want this disease
we're labeling it. In a sense, there's nothing wrong with that. But in other sense, there's a lot
wrong with that. And we have to have that balance in how strictly we judge things. And that is really
one of the deeper things of why I had titled my books over the years ago. Stop fighting cancer.
It's our treat of the cause as I wrote in the last chapter in that book. I think it's been so long since
I read it. That it's about really accepting what our lot is in life. And not that we don't use wisdom
to try to change it. Okay, so I have cancer and I don't want to have cancer. So Lord, what should I do
to deal with this? Should I get chemotherapy? Yes, no, maybe I should do radiation. Should I do an
alternative? Should I change my diet? And we gather wisdom from a multitude of sources. And then we
balance that out with our relationship with God. That is restored as it could, as it was in the
Garden of Eden that we can walk with an indwelling Holy Spirit and have a relationship with our
Heavenly Father. And no beyond the pieces that pass us all understand what we're supposed to do.
But when we see it and we all do this, I do this every single day that we fall into this judging
mentality of labeling things as good and bad at our body and our life and our experiences
that it warps our thinking and it takes our mind off of eternity and puts our mind on the temporal.
And that's when we need a fellowship of people that will remind us to not do that and to get out of that.
And we need that fellowship of people to remind us because it is inevitable in our flesh that we are
going to fall and we are going to start doing this. So it's so easy to start feeling sorry for ourselves
when we're not getting what we want. What we have labeled as good, which might be, if you're dealing
with the serious diagnosis, it might be health. That's good. In ill health, well, that's bad. But
in God's Heavenly Kingdom, that's not good or bad. It is what it is. And everything can be used to
His glory to bring us closer to Him. And it's part of God's disciple leader, bold leader,
shaping us if we allow it to make us more like His Son so that we can be more glorious to Him on earth.
And we can glorify Him in every way possible here on earth. And that's my challenge to you
to think about it, no matter where you are from a spiritual perspective today, to instead of
labeling things in our life, even though it might be something that the average person out there
would label bad. How can you label cancer good? I'm saying don't label it good or bad, just it is
what it is. How can I take this situation and give God glory in it and have Him be glorified in it?
We spoke to somebody today that their cancer has spread and they're considering doing chemo and where
their cancer is. I said it would probably be the best idea to do that. And they just had such a
godly attitude about it. And they were just well, they know that God's in this too. And
that he's got to play it in this as well. And this is not the road that they wanted to walk,
but it may be the road that God has them to walk. And that is, I believe that what I gave
my life to Jesus Christ. It's not my life anymore. I gave it to him. And if he wants to use me
to go through chemo for whatever reason I've said before, maybe it's to witness to a chemo nurse,
maybe it's to be able to witness to somebody in that road just in my lifestyle. Maybe it's for others
and I think this is so often the case. God allows us to go through things so that others,
when they look at us, they see our reaction to it. How do we react when quote unquote bad things
happen? Are we reacted? Are we freaky? Don't I understand that's our human tendency? But how do we
react when it all comes down? Where is our heart really settling? And I want for myself for it to
settle on, unrested in him. And that's really the fight of good fights that Paul talks about.
It is a wrestling match to rest in God. It is a fight to not want to pick it up and do it myself.
That is the biggest struggle sometimes in my life is to trust and to not judge in my intelligence
and wisdom of what's good or what's bad. The Bible is very clear in one verse is one of my favorite
verses. It says, this too shall pass. It's a really comforting verse when you're going to really
trouble times. This too shall pass. And things aren't going the way you want it and you got a bad
diagnosis so you're not feeling well or your finances are followed apart. This too shall pass.
But it's also a sobering verse when you're at the top of the world and you just got a new boat
and you're going to the cabin and your family's all attacked and everything's going right because this
too shall pass. We live in a fallen world with all sorts of quote unquote bad things happening
all around us. People die of in car accidents at 16 years old. People get hit by a drug driver
of no fault in their home. People have accidents that they couldn't prevent. How does this happen?
We label it bad. We get a diagnosis that we don't want. Oh, that's bad. But if we could just take
a step out of the temporal for a moment and stop labeling that and see it from an eternal perspective
that this little tedious sliver of time that I call life in the realm of eternity that is forever
and ever and ever and ever it has no end. It's really the anxiety and the worry and the troubles
that I allow by flesh to take me through. It's kind of silly. But it is our flesh. It is our
tendency and God knows our weakness and Jesus Himself walked through the same struggles.
So is it not to shame us for feeling bad or to mean bad or to go through anger or to go through
different emotions that we go through? But it's an encouragement to push us to settle on the
place after we go through all these mixed emotions that our humaneness comes out and it spews out
and spills out on the people and it gets kind of ugly sometimes. That it settles out on
a resting in the purposes of God that are bigger than my desires. I gave myself to him and if he
wants to choose me to go through cancer for some reason that I will not know until I get to the other
side then that's his prerogative. And he loves me enough to put me through that and I love him enough
to trust him that he is the God who raises the dead and I get a sped eternity with him.
So that's my encouragement for you today. Rebeburet our judgment is not always healthy for us
and our fight of good fight is to rest in the plan of God. And when we do have to make a decision
what should I do chemo? Should I not do chemo? Should I take this medication? Should I not take this
medication? Should I call my son? I haven't talked to him for years. I have not talked to him.
Should I drop that relationship? Should I not drop that relationship? Should I deal with this
financial burden? Should I not deal with this? It should always go back to the wisdom of God
and our relationship with God and see things through a eternal perspective. That's my little
soapbox challenge for you today. Now let's get to the questions.
Ever what I'm wondering what you think of IV therapy specifically vitamin C infusions
to increase progesterone levels? Good question though there's numerous studies on progesterone
and estrogen function with IV vitamin C. There's numerous studies that show just taking vitamin C
will help boost progesterone levels and women that have low progesterone levels but there's also
studies that show high dose vitamin C can actually decrease progesterone levels and could decrease
estrogen levels. And there's other studies that show otherwise. So it's difficult to assess it.
I think the studies are variable because it's variable in different people.
So really I don't know that I would purposely take IV vitamin C to increase progesterone levels.
If that's my whole purpose of what's to try to increase progesterone levels I wouldn't do
IV vitamin C to do that. However if IV vitamin C that's the one of the headups is it can increase
estrogen levels and that's one of the problems with cancer patients. So if you are doing IV vitamin
C therapy we don't do it in this office but if you are doing that it would be for you to get your estrogen
levels checked just to make sure that that's not that's not spiking. Another question that came in
would be was my sister started taking superbeats supplement advertised on TV. She swears in lower
than her husband's blood pressure that has helped with digestion and energy. Do you have an opinion
of any beats supplements that you provide? Okay so a superbeats supplement is just a really it's
another way of just juicing. So all the powdered beats the powdered greens in such a way of juicing
I would say that this person probably would have very similar effects if they took a green supplement too.
Beats are really good for your liver. Beats can be good for your blood. The only negative
with beats is they can be higher in sugar so you do need to look at the sugar content of it.
People that are juicida typically especially if they have liver gallbladder issues I suggest
juiced beats the dehydrated beats supplements like that superbeats product are other great products too.
We don't use that because we use the greens first product that has a more balanced nutrition in it
it has a bunch of other things but I think in general I think those powdered
supplements like the powdered beats are really really good supplements so we don't carry that
simply because we carry the greens and it's a more balanced product for people and those who need
more straight beats could get that through juiced and the other thing is is that
beats do contain more sugar so you have to be careful taking too much of those.
Next question. Should I consider with any oh should I be concerned with dairy intake that's
what it was even if I'm not sensitive to dairy and I put this slide back up there because yes
everybody should be concerned with dairy intake even if you're not a cancer patient you should be
concerned with dairy intake so this is a great slide to demonstrate what dairy does so dairy remember
let's just go back to what is dairy so dairy's purpose is to make a little baby grow quickly
so dairy even if it's raw dairy organic dairy grass fed dairy the best dairy on the planet
dairy still has a lot of IGF1 hormone that's a growth factor hormone in it so we're not talking about
added hormones to make the cow produce more milk we're talking about just what is in
any mother's milk that will help a baby grow large and quick is IGF1 so IGF1 is in all dairy other
hormones are in dairy too because it's a secretion of the mother's gland so that is going to stimulate
emptor dairy also has a lot of protein and if your if your cancer is stimulated by different
amino acids that can stimulate it but all those things also stimulate emptor so we could say
amino acids can stimulate cancer itself or both stimulate cancer itself IGF1 stimulates cancer growth
itself too also stimulates emptor secondarily stimulating growth of any tissue that's what it does
so dairy is supposed to have these things in there so it stimulates emptor up regulates the
emptor pathway so it increases growth so you know how often should a person be e dairy if they don't
have cancer my answer is it should be raw and it should be not very often so well I don't disagree
I agree because agree with that because God even promised that the Israelites were going to be
going into a country of a land flowing with milk and honey there if that's dairy well yes it is but how
often did they eat dairy drink dairy there's there's not a lot of instances that suggests there was
a lot of use of dairy so I would I would suggest that we eat way too much dairy in this country
yeah if you didn't have any dairy sensitivities and you had antibodies your antibodies to KC checks
so that you don't have antibodies to KC don't have any lactose intolerance issues and you don't have
cancer could you have some raw dairy once in a while absolutely should you be having it every day
like typical American has absolutely not and in the form that a typical American has double not
so dairy is an issue even if you don't have a sensitivity you don't have dairy KC antibodies you
don't have lactose intolerance still dairy is an issue because it just makes your body grow your cells grow
quickly it could increase weight it could increase all sorts of problems so dairy is for babies it
for adults occasionally all right so that was the only questions that came in so now I'm going to
unmute you all and open it up to questions and see if you guys have anything that you want to share
or argue about or debate or get a big fight with Dr. Connor this is Deb Swartz I just came to see you
Monday and I was treated with the heat lamps and the sound therapy and the PEMF
now I'm having pain down my neck and clavicle and just on the left side could that possible
be from congested lymph from being overkill or from kill off I doubt it no doubt your left side of your
front to your back it's the front so doubt your left side here to be a little more specific there say
say under your chin to clavicle clavicle to under the left arm so the only way that that would be
that I would say that would be kill off as if a person who was killing a sinus infection or
something like that and you were working on that because your live drains from your from your both
your face on the left side down your anterior posterior live chains of your cervical spine
right into your your fetus system there it doesn't go any further down your chest from there
so if your pain goes down but it down your neck and your left side of your body that doesn't really
flow that doesn't really follow the pattern it is it is a sharp pain a dull pain is it what is it sharp
like if I move it hurts if I keep still I'm okay okay so that sounds more like some bustle
spasibar something I there's it's not really a referral area there maybe a rib out of place or something
chiropractor adjustment maybe that would be a good idea okay one more question oh you said
there was a biological contributing to this condition anyway biological you mean parasite
bacteria viral yeah so a biotoxin so a biotoxin is a virus bacteria the old fungus parasite
I can't find tell me to look for a general program but I cannot find one if I want for the lungs
but it's only for um I would do the viral complex program thank you one more thing and I won't
ask more than the healthy living newsletter from the secret people who are hosting a conference this
I don't know I can't remember September anyway they were saying that they're using that technology
now to help um quill body memory or lifting up that emotional aspects of illness
did you are you planning on attending that or investing because that's it Italy so I don't like
why not are so I'm not going to go to Italy but I will be getting the information of that and I
think they're going to have a new program coming out that fits in your system so if they do
we'll get that to you for sure oh thank you so much all right that's it that's all I need no thank you
doctor kind of um I wish I could tell you exactly the um name for this that you probably will
know anyway I can't remember the name of it but two different people approached me with this
machinery that they're saying is it sounds like a multi-level marketing kind of situation where
they try to get people to either buy it or get treatments but you lay down on a pad on the floor
and they cover you up with a pad and it's like what it might be some type of light therapy and it's
supposed to help with circulation and and people are squaring by this that it's it's helping cure
diseases and yeah is it a beaver is that what you're saying yeah yeah so a beaver is a low-frequency
PE of F um and they're good they're good little units by only problem with the beaver beaver is
they're so overpriced because they're multi-level marketing if you want to get a low-frequency
PE of F get what Deb just talked about and get the seaquics because that is programmable it's the only
low-frequency PE of F that's programmable and it's about $3,000 less expensive so the beavers about $7,500
the the seaquics is about $4800 or something like that so does that just help with general health
or could it actually like the second really help with cancer it does not it does not kill cancer
what it does is it just helps with general health like a high-frequency PE of F but you you lay it
for a period of time half hour to an hour a day and it just helps recharge the cells
the reason why I like the seaquics is because it runs through a bunch of different frequencies
that are programmed to you where the beaver is running through just a few standard frequencies
which is still good I'm not saying that beavers are bad units yeah but I just think that you you have
to be really careful because there's no since since they're marketed by lay people lay people could
like say anything they want and that you have to be careful about that yeah and it's nothing even
close to what the rife machine was right oh it's not even it's not even it's a it's a PE of F
that's not a rife machine so it's it's not even the same category oh so it's it would be more
of the category of of the PE of F that you used here except not really there either so there's
the difference between the high frequency PE of F and the low frequency PE of F they're like two
completely different therapies both of them have validity both of them are good and the beaver is a
low frequency PE enough and then you know there's that's what the sequence is too and that I
about rest is another brand out there they're good little units too and they're actually they're a lot
cheaper than the beaver too okay thank you um Dr. Conner sounds as he does I was there a couple weeks ago
and um I could use some of the mission initial first time and um when I
oh yeah I noticed that I was really um the the lymph was really really so it was probably because of
the of the acoustic you did that right you did the sound one okay so the the biggest thing that
helps the the lymph is the is the sequence in the acoustic I would say okay I did those two
yeah I would say it was probably what of those two no kidding all right because it was it was you
know it was like dramatically better well why don't you come up here and stay for a while
I don't have to do next time I guess I'm on my way we have just entered Rhode Island so I like
okay I'm gonna be with my grandson for a while now it will be all right so thank you
I'm I'm a little lost about what the seaquics is that you're talking about so the seaquics is a low
frequency PE of F we might not have it when you were here oh okay I don't know when did you come
we got it yeah we got it December okay um it's a low frequency PE of F that we have we have an
office professional unit that can then scare you and then you can you can purchase a home unit
that we we write those programs at a card and then you can run it at home every day and there
those are the units that are like $4800 or so that would be equivalent to the Bieber but I think
it's much better than the Bieber and the Bieber is more expensive okay all right any other questions
yes okay uh this is Donna Bridgier from Arkansas and I got my thermography um then he called
me about my thermography yesterday and um he was talking about the length and the exercises that are
in the notebook um we don't have a rebounder but I I was wondering if there was another exercise
that I could use that both Mike and I could use together walking or biking or yeah when you know
whatever um yeah so the idea of helping helping live phatic congestion is in order for
live to move through the live vessels it requires contraction of muscles so by doing anything
that will help that will involve contraction muscles is going to help with live flow the other problem
with live congestion isn't the flow of the live the Bieber it is the uh stasis of the extra cellular the
fluid outside of the cells um it's the stasis of that and not able for it to get into the live vessels
so when a person has quote-unquote live phatic congestion there's two possible problems um happening
what is that they're not moving so if I have a job and all I do is sit all day and I walk to the
car drive home and go sit on the couch and I'm not doing any contraction muscles are very little
I can get swelling in the quote-unquote live phatic congestion and it's because I'm not using
my muscles another person can be doing a whole bunch of exercise but they still have a lot of live phatic
congestion and it's because of the the the extra cellular that means the outside of your cell
the you can get a protein matrix that binds up and it basically the fluid between the cells
gets kind of cloggy gets congested gets gets thick gets viscous
and it's not able to get into the into the live system very well well that's where motion will help
with it too increasing water intake will help with that uh and you know vibration helps with that
so like a vibration plate will help with that um and uh but something to do together if you
if if it's like I get in some swelling or my feet I want to just keep my lymph flowing I'd say
really start with just going out walking um and swinging your arms and moving your body
you know guard need get out doing some things outside yes I'm pretty active you know we used to walk um
you know uh you have to run um five p and it's onto walking um so um but we have a farm
though we are very active like we said I don't sit around all day but I was just wanting to try
to find something um that that we could do together um because we like to do things together
that's good and he needs six because I do as well as I do yeah that's good I'd say get out walking
make sure you're swimming try to swing your arms and do a little kind of you don't have to go fast
but kind of a race walk look you know where you're doing more of an exaggerated step not the whole time
but it's sometimes so you're moving you're trying to contract as many different muscles as possible
okay is that being weight-help sure because you're just anything that's contracted muscles that's
going to help okay all right I can do that I had one of the questions I've seen the video today about
lectins uh-huh and proxines that are in the gut um can you um kind of take me on those a little bit
yep so lectins are a component of a lot of different foods all right there's a lot of good foods
that are high in lectins now it's really it's it's not that many people that have major problems with
lectins and it's both people that have other dietary concerns as well so if you have a standard
america diet and you're not eating well um you're going to develop sensitivities to a whole bunch of
different foods and we could run a food sensitivity blood panel on you and there's going to be
we really want to coat the things you can't eat because there's too many things you can't eat
it's those are the people with a lot of damage got and they develop high sensitivity so as you
clean out a person's diet and clean up their diet uh and start healing the gut you start to not have
issues with those things um as I know it's you you're listening you're watching videos and seeing
Facebook ads out there are different things it can get so confusing because goodness
takes I can't eat anything um but in truth you you have to look at things also from a from a
perspective of how did God make us to eat um and our tomatoes which have a lot of lectins in
are they something we should eat well sure but are they something we need to eat every single day
it's about having that balance and I've always been an advocate of trying to eat and seize it but
what it takes you could go to the grocery store and get apples any time of the year
used to be only you could buy apples in the fall but um I think there's a purpose behind the
plan of of of harvest that things are not available all the time um and there's a purpose and we get
back to doing like a fasting type diet now and then a fasting though and then it fasting certain
foods now and then we especially um uh from a cultural standpoint get in the habit of eating the same type
of things uh you know your Italian eats spaghetti sauce and pasta every day well you're going to have
gluten issues and you're going to have lectin issues and you're going to have vasoactive amy
issues for the tomatoes too and you're going to have all sorts of problems because we weren't
meant to eat that way so we're meant to eat a rotational diet with a lot of different mixes
learning to fast I mean a full you know um time fasting time restricted eating at different times
and it's fasting with different times okay very well thank you so much okay okay well I will get
this um uh recording up on YouTube and about our Facebook page and please keep the questions coming
in on the Facebook page and you want anything answered the zoom call uh said those in as well
I wish you all a nice word August afternoon and though I'll be praying for all of you have a
wonderful day thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you